fresh off another remarkable outing in
his first ballot Pro Football Hall of
Fame career a big-time win over the
Atlanta Falcons in the spot where the
Super Bowl is going down so this
gentleman is hoping he played his first
of two games in Atlanta this year Super
Bowl champion and Super Bowl MVP
and a man in its 18th season good lord
in the National Football League none
other than Drew Brees how are you drew
so great rich yeah I'm doing fine I'm
doing fine and I'm appreciative of you
ringing in a couple of days later how
does a game like that feel when your
next day day after stuff drew it feels
good you know body's a little less sore
listen a hard-fought game and we we knew
it was gonna be a battle at all they're
a football team extremely explosive
offense you know it's one of those games
where he potentially deceptive you know
and that's kind of want to turned out to
be it was back and forth I know I just
it's not like a we take the lead and
they would take you know it's just you
know man
a lot of playmakers on both sides of the
ball but I think we knew just how
significant this this game would be and
certainly win in Atlanta would be you
know for us for our team for this season
just as we continue to progress you know
I I feel like we're getting a little bit
better each and every week I think it is
a great sense of urgency just to
continue to improve and and and
re-establish our identity you know I
mean we had we had high expectations
coming into the season you know after
last season we had a lot of a lot of the
same guys in this locker room you know a
lot of young players are kind of coming
into their own and but still each season
is a new season and it's a new team how
to re-establish that identity each and
every year so a win like this goes a
long way with building confidence and
creating that momentum so and things
don't happen just by luck but that could
be the residue of design you're as
prepared as anybody in the business so
let me ask you I ask you how often have
you practiced that spinorama that got
you in the end zone to force overtime
drew Brees
giving a name to spin the spinner alia
to spin around it's funny because so I I
coached my boys in flag football every
every Friday night here in the hall a
fantastic and I keep telling me get my
guys spin rooms are good know like get
to the defender and it's just easy to
see your flags and clarifies the man you
give them a though it's amazing you know
the kids can't track the flags and
you'll get past them so now I have video
evidence that spin moves work so I'm
breaking it out to the kids which week
so you you practice what you preach drew
brees that's what you're saying no lip
service I was telling I was saying on
the show the yesterday that watching
that you know was up on the big screen
at the NFL Network and there was about
20-25 people in the room that was we we
all just audibly went ooh at the same
time it was an O and O moment drew when
you spun off and got in the end zone
that's quite something
well I mean that might have been part of
the you but I was also like we're not we
were not expecting two defenders to be
bearing down on you and you spun out of
it and caught in the end zone a force
overtime you know yeah well those in
desperate times call for desperate bad
you have to get to had to get the
touchdown to 7:30 and and then you know
put together a 12-play drive to go down
and win the whole thing so man just just
kind of that whole that whole sequence
you know that last Drive and then
obviously the driving over time just you
know very methodical you know everybody
contributing just getting a little bit
of the time converting a bunch of third
downs to put ourselves in position win
the game
drew Brees Saints quarterback here on
the Rich Eisen show you've had some very
talented people at your disposal
throughout your career drew but I mean
this kid Michael Thomas and Alvin Kamara
they are young and dynamic and
multi-talented is this the most talented
weapon read that you've had it you
our disposal in your career you think
yeah I've had a chance to play with some
great ones here you know but obviously
we're pretty excited about what what
those two guys bring to the table like
you said man super dynamic and you know
my cat wide receiver a guy who you know
at anytime you say him like man let's go
make a play you know and he's going to
get open for you and not a more
competitive guy either I love the way
that he practices I love the way that he
competes every day I mean honestly what
you see on the field is what happens in
practice every day with Michael Thomas
so what you see is what you get I love
that Alvin Kamara you know the same way
just such a smooth fluid athlete
extremely intelligent is such a weapon
obviously coming out you know running
the ball there's not many as natural
runners as him but then get him out of
that backfield in the passing game and
he's basically like a receiver as well
so yeah those two guys obviously with
the complement of the others that we
have minutes buy weapons and when it's
all said and done the way that your
season has started now two wins after a
home loss to Fitzpatrick who's he's he's
something else isn't he that Ryan
Fitzpatrick group somebody's been doing
it as long as you have you know I mean
we were talking about we were talking
about the other day when Aaron Rodgers
and Alex Smith were going against each
other that was for the first two
quarterbacks in the Oh five draft the
last quarterback taken in that draft is
also started week three and suraíh
Fitzpatrick unbelievable I did not know
that
that's a damn an you got a you got a
roof of the old guys
he said when they're playing against you
I know exactly how we wanted that he's
played he's played marvelous last last
two weeks another play Monday Night
Football
oh man it's I don't know something about
experience wisdom of the agent treachery
you know well when it comes down to it
how does the feeling that you have in
that locker room with this team relate
to last year when you were on the verge
of something special as well you know
it's like I look around and listen a lot
of space
a lot of a lot of those graphics from
last year as rookies ended up becoming
really productive players for us you
know and maybe a little bit before you
expect
guys like Marcela Marcus Williams Tamara
you just don't know what you get with
these guys I mean oh they're gonna be so
talented nice and I'm you know I'm a
right tackle Ryan I'm Tech that math
class I mean guys that came in and
literally took just about every snap you
know and obviously contributed a ton to
our success and so you know going from
year one to year two you know you expect
you know continued improvement and but
also you know you don't I think you
always worry about you know you don't
want that complacency to set in like a
you know this is kind of easy you know
yeah you'll snap away from in the NFC
Championship and potentially beyond but
man you just you got a reinforced eyes
just man such a such a sense of urgency
you know when you have these
opportunities take advantage of them
them this doesn't come around every day
or every season mmm
I think we got a special group I love
our locker room mindset that we've taken
off season the man you really don't know
what you're gonna see I think start
happening there man which last two games
we've had to wait you know go know the
wire we've had to win in pretty crazy
fashion you know with with everyone
contributing really all three phases no
we we uh we block apart you know in the
game just Atlanta that sets us up for a
touchdown and you know defense comes up
with a big stop at the end of the game
the forces overtime then we drive it
down the field offense going man
everybody's everybody's in these
Williams but I thought about confidence
being built know you know that you can
win in a lot of different ways just a
couple more minutes left here with Drew
Brees fresh off of that big win in
Atlanta what is a braking force
completion record mean to you
um you know listen it's significant I I
really I really can't reflect on things
too much now as I'm playing and I'm
still under staying in the moment you
know and I'm focused on the next week
the next opportunity yes don't just play
with this giant chip on my shoulder like
approve and I've got the rules to
achieve you know I've got goals for this
King to achieve and it's just you know
what I've done playing I can call this
saying hey it's pretty cool but it does
it does make me feel very very grateful
very very grateful to have had the
opportunity to play in the NFL this long
to have played with some of the players
and coaches but I've had a chance to be
around that have influenced my learner's
in such a powerful way and given giving
me these opportunities and this record
is really for for so many people it's
for the Saints organization it's for
every person who's ever caught a pass
that's right and blocked and you know
there's this record belongs all of them
and you know when it's all said and done
obviously you'll look back on it and
you've had an incredible amount of
longevity so I asked this question of
you knowing that you've been at it for
as long as you have and the roughing the
passer rule drew that seems to have been
reinforced by the the league office to
protect quarterbacks like when you were
out there on the field against Atlanta
one happened involving Clay Matthews
again that I'm sure you've seen since
then what are your thoughts on the r.e.m
phasis that the league is placed on this
and and and whether you think the league
should reconsider it or you think
they've got its spot on here it's tough
it's tough
listen I'm I play quarterback so I'm a
beneficiary of this rule right but just
as a football player and as a guy who's
been around a long time
like I'm a little confused by it you
know I mean I I get the I get the
frustration I think it's hard to play
defensive line right now you know and
knowing how you're gonna hit the
quarterback or how you're going to
tackle the quarterback and what's what's
not going to draw a flag you know
I like to say that in many cases the
common sense you know as the league or
as an official Dominion listen the
officials are in a tough spot because
they're trying to take what is the the
letter of the law and apply that to you
know what they see and how they call the
game and I'm just I don't think I don't
think it's I don't think it's working
you know again I'm a bit as a
quarterback I'm a beneficiary of this
you know but I also understand and it's
hard to play defense right now with with
the way some of these rules are written
and listen I I still think there's
there's rule changes that that need to
be made that will continue to improve
things
you know you defenseless receivers
downfield so they say you can't hit him
in the head anymore so what are
defenders doing will there hit them in
the knees well that's just as bad you
know because because you're seeing guys
get up with these knee injuries and
ankle injuries and such because they're
getting targeted low because that's
where defenders feel like is the only
place to hit them you know so I think
there has to be a rule change with kind
of a target zone where where you can hit
defenseless receivers you know I think
it's below the neck and uh you know and
around the waist or thigh bone area you
know so I don't know I mean listen
there's there's always improvements to
be made it's all in the spirit of making
the game safer right it's all in the
spirit of trying to prevent injuries but
I just think maybe there's a better way
to define it and then and then obviously
a way to to call it and judge it on
Sunday yeah I mean I asked this of Jason
Kelsey on Monday show do you think there
might be some groundswell of the players
to go to the NFL and I know it sounds
strange thing you're protecting us too
much but how about the players going to
them because you're you're just the
latest core Alex Smith himself said on
Sunday that he thought that the hit you
should not have been flagged I mean what
about the players saying something to
the NFL on mass that maybe something
should be done on that front yeah yeah
they could I mean I don't I don't think
that the NFL's typically pretty slow to
react to stuff like that and obviously
it's not a change
that can be made midseason you know this
is any changes that are made at the end
of the season or during the off season
you know the competition goat community
goes through that whole process and then
you know you give it to the officials
then any official spend a couple weeks
at NFL training camps and during the
preseason games getting a feel and a
grasp for how they're going to call it
you know so there's there's all this
time on task that has to take place it's
not like you just instantly you know
institute a rule change and and then all
of a sudden they have to start seeing it
differently you know things are things
happen so fast out there but listen it's
it's tough I don't think we're gonna
film the problem on the phone here but
yeah I I definitely I definitely I
definitely think I definitely think
there's there's room for improvement
well you got Eli Manning and the Giants
coming up next that'll be always
interesting when you see somebody from
the old one NFL Draft class go against
the ou4 that'll be that'll be
fascinating and then then you got your
necks before that your next flag
football game who do you sound most
likely you got some shot in arm Ernie
you got some tiller in you a little Sean
Payton what what's your coaching
influence when you're out there with
those kids drew a little bit of all
three okay you take two take all my
exposure you know from all the great
coaches and put that into them now
granted you know talking like first
who's been like a certain fourth grade
team here but we're not getting too
crazy yet you know we're not it's it's
cut it's kind of like you know that
what's the scene from wedding crashers
you know when they when they go and it's
been slow on and and uh was it Owen
Wilson and there's like hot route hot
route he's like I don't know what you're
talking about
so there's no dress code on the road
trips yet is what you're saying
there's no dress code on the road job
okay it's very very casual
a lot of times were just trying to try
to get this map you know I got just hey
look I got three kids on tenant under
and you've got four and
I can't believe by the way that little
boy on that Super Bowl night with
confetti coming down and the headsets on
a protect his ears is nine years old I
cannot believe that it's unbelievable I
know I know and he's the quarterback for
his fourth grade football team so does
he lick his lips like his dad I mean
what does he got does he get his game a
little bit there I have some crazy quirk
the guy wants I like some stuff on so
much so much right now he's not quite
there yet okay
he might develop he's got time to come
as long as he goes to the big ten big
drew that's all I ask you know obviously
hey that's right I'm a big test right
take care of yourself there you go take
care of yourself drew brees I really
appreciate the time let's chat again
soon good you got at you a breeze on
Twitter Drew Brees of the New Orleans
Saints here in the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience